La politique, c'est le terrain,
c’est le partage, c'est aller vers l'autre,
c'est ce que je fais 24/24.
Badia Allard,
adjointe au maire de Reims,
délégation handicap et ville inclusive
et je suis la seule délégation en France.
Je viens du domaine associatif.
Mon parcours professionnel :
j'ai fait une formation de juriste.
Par ma différence, pendant un moment,
j'ai été obligée d'arrêter
parce que l'accessibilité,
m’a coupé l'herbe sous le pied.
Après, j'ai élevé mes trois enfants
tout en travaillant.
Je suis élue depuis 2020.
Plusieurs années que je travaille à coté
du président du MoDem de la Marne :
Franck Noël.
J'étais à côté de lui comme associatif,
je représentais le handicap.
En 2020,
Monsieur le maire,
m'a fait appel pour que je rentre
dans sa nouvelle municipalité.
Depuis que je suis à cette délégation,
il a fallu le temps
pour la faire exister.
Depuis trois ans,
j'ai réussi,
on a le service, on a la délégation,
on a des personnes qui travaillent
avec la délégation handicap.
J'ai accepté d'être
sur la liste au MoDem ?
C'est grâce à Franck Noël.
Je me trouve dans le MoDem,
tout ce que je fais sur le terrain.
J'ai trouvé ma politique à moi.
Ma politique, c'est le terrain.
Ma politique, c'est d'être proche de l'autre,
c'est d'aller voir l’autre.
La politique qui est la vraie,
c'est pas rester derrière un bureau.